foreign
I didn't notice because as the author of
the system it was always clear to me
what whether it was a macro or a
procedure call
and without looking at the index you
have no way to know
right now so probably it would be a good
idea to have a little typographic symbol
indicating it's a macro call or
something
where
module parents no
no the see when you when you call a
macro you uh
I might even want to have a indicated by
a by a subscript which tells me what's
the module number where the macro was
defined that would be another way it
would no it would say Inc or sub 3 then
you'd know that that was a macro
because it has a subscript on it
procedure named Stone
um so I like to experiment with that
it's a problem that I just that I wasn't
aware of until this week yeah
I guess they they've started to tape so
we so if people want to make comments so
we ought to uh do it for the for the
people out in TV Land all right so well
let's continue this discussion later and
this is uh six down and six to go
and uh our current
um
our current uh this thing under
discussion will be the paragraph
um maker and a couple of uh well yeah we
can talk about web later
um now uh okay put it in context again
we'll give this old slide and I have
another slide that you haven't seen
before that you'll get to see in a
minute
so the paragraphs uh it counts for a
little bit of code here about what is
that uh 10 100 modules
and uh and if you add hyphenation to
that which is which is about an uh about
the same amount of code uh this this is
the thing that takes place when a
horizontal list has been finished and
it's time to break it up and um and and
put it into boxes of the age size
uh it's a self-contained little part of
the program that that only gets called
taught in two places once it gets called
when you uh have finished an ordinary
paragraph in the other places when
you've started a displayed equation in
both cases you take the previous lines
and make them up into paragraph there's
uh one of the things in the state we
remember we had the mode and the head
and the tail and the space Factor
there's another thing in the state
called already and this is it this keeps
track of how many lines you've already
set for a paragraph in case of a
displayed formula you have to have to
resume maybe at line eight or nine the
reason is that these paragraphs can be
um can have hanging indentation and the
Hang imitation might say go on for the
first 10 lines and so you have to
remember how many lines you've already
done
in the in Tech you know that you can
also play games with the uh with
paragraphs and you can get different
shapes something like that and uh and
specify the part the paragraph shape so
it's another reason why we want to know
how many lines we've uh We've set you
could have a displayed equation in the
middle of such of such paragraphs what
what actually what tech actually does is
it considers a displayed equation is
three lines long and all three lines are
are equal in size to the uh to the uh
middle of those three lines usually the
first and last are blank and uh the only
time that um that you have other lines
is if you have to drop an equation
number or or raise an equation number
now there's tiny little numbers in the
right hand margin here
um this is indicate this is the the glue
ratio of the that had to be used in that
line if you could read it it would in
the first line it would say 0.305 says
the new spaces are a little larger by by
three tenths of their stretchability the
next one point eight six seven
here's a mine whoops where's the minus
yeah the bottom one is a minus 0.517 and
um
this is in some sense the optimum way to
put those words into that shape and we
change the text a few to other texts and
we could fit them in in um also there
was no it wasn't particularly difficult
to to uh uh to do this example we didn't
have to we didn't have to fudge with it
or anything very much but the question
is what kind of algorithm is actually
used to make paragraphs and it's one of
the most interesting algorithms in Tech
probably the most interesting one
um
and it's due uh in major part to Michael
Place who's whose wife you all know
because she's been our Host this week
um
now
let's first talk about the case where we
don't have a paragraph shape and all the
lines are the same length
this is this diagram indicates one of
the tests that we have carried out over
and over again to to our to our favorite
text this is the text taken from Grimm's
Fairy Tales and the only reason we did
this is that for some reason somebody
puts Grimm's Fairy Tales online in the
sale computer system this is fairy tale
number one and the first paragraph of
fairy tale number one if you want to
read the rest of the fairy tale I have
it online and we can look at it later
and all the other Tales are on there too
and we also have Wuthering Heights but I
don't and uh and we have
oh goodness what was Colin Higgins first
movie um
heroin mod yeah okay so those are the
books that we have online and we've been
we can do our experiments on
paragraphing with those with those
things also there happens I guess the
art of computer programming is online
now well
um
in olden times when wishing still helped
one there lived the king and so on this
is the paragraph and
um the question is what's the best way
to put it into into a paragraph and Tech
has its way to define best in terms of
concepts of Badness and demerits Badness
is something that depends on that that
little glue ratio number that we had on
there this one is so smeary I can't even
read it off of the slide but it's 0.7
something on that Top Line now the um
the Badness is uh in in simple cases is
equal to the cube of that number times a
hundred
um so if it's 0.7 we Cube it to get 0.49
and then what uh three is it 343 is 7
cubed so 0.34 so 34.3 units of Badness
uh because we multiply by 100 afterwards
now this hundred of course is an
arbitrary squaring Factor but then we
convert to an integer and this this
calculation of Badness is actually done
by uh like all the other things it take
with integers by some precise method
that you're not uh allowed to deal with
so the actual calculation of getting
that thing uh uh we didn't compute the
blue ratio with floating Point
arithmetic we had the true integer
number of um of uh scale points that we
wanted to expand that line by and we had
the true integer number of of
stretchability that we could do it and
those two numbers were computed by a
subroutine called Badness that will
produce probably the number 34 maybe 35
but whatever number it produces every
implementation of tech is supposed to
produce exactly that same number and
it's pretty much the ratio of the two
time cubed times 100. and the reason
that number was chosen was because it
has the right properties for that we
were looking for namely it's pretty it
stays close to zero for a while
um and then but then it starts to rise
rapidly after things start to get real
bad
um then once we have Badness we add on
to that
another number called the line penalty
which just says that any line has a
certain amount of uh that is has
something uh wrong with it just because
we don't want to waste lines and so line
penalty and Tech the old version of tech
was always fixed at one but in Tech 82
you can say the line penalty is 100 and
that'll make it that'll make Tech uh a
lot less happy to to to make a paragraph
longer it'll try to you know the larger
line penalty the the uh the short of the
paragraphs will tend to be
and then it's funny if you try to set
line penalty negative
um strange things are gonna strange
things will happen and uh well I that's
not news about that for someone anyway
there's there's a whole there's a whole
bunch of other parameters that um can be
played with so many that that I doubt if
anybody will ever be able to to
experiment with with very many of them
in their lifetime I mean there's just
that many possibilities to try you so
you find ones that you like and with
those but uh
um the line penalty is one of these
parameters so we take the Badness
computer as I told you we add the line
penalty then
um we add penalties associated with this
particular kind of a break so if some if
there's a break at the end of a line
it's due to a hyphen then then you add
on the hyphenation penalty there's two
kinds of those there's the kind that
there was a discretionary hyphen and
there's the kind that was an explicit
hyphen uh like if somebody has a dash or
a real hyphen in his text uh where he
said
um nitty-gritty or something and there
was a hyphen there in in that there's a
that's an explicit hyphen that gets one
penalty the kind that had to be inserted
is hyphenation algorithm that gets
another kind of anyway that that penalty
would be added or if you sit broke
because of an implicit penalty that you
said penalty 100 then the penalty is of
course a hundred now we calculate the
demerits of a line by taking the this
Badness and the line penalty and the
other penalty and add those all together
and square it
um
uh yes and that's demerits
um and and the the Morgan merits you
have the worse you're off uh uh now uh
on the other hand if the penalty is is
negative for example if somebody said uh
break here with penalty minus 100 then
we don't want to subtract 100 and then
squared because that's going to go the
wrong way so in that case we compute the
square the Badness and we subtract the
square of the penalty
um now these are arbitrary formulas but
they tend to to agree with what what
it's supposed to do namely as the
penalty gets larger this demerits go uh
go up and uh and uh they tend to uh to
produce the right results so we had to
have a way to find a quantitative
statement how much does it cost you for
a certain uh a certain uh effects on the
page so so the costs are computed by by
a mathematical formula finally we get to
a notion of demerits and the idea is to
find the way to break the paragraph so
that the total number of demerits is as
small as possible yeah
now this particular example
um
we
can illustrate that problem by this neat
little chart here where we where I draw
on each line the number of demerits that
would be associated with the line from a
break at this at this dot means the
beginning of the paragraph here's a
break after the word a so on the first
line which had uh 0.7 something of
Badness
um so that would be 34 and so on and
after squaring and everything
uh it turned out to be
adding line families growing so on we
turned out that it was 2357 demerits for
that line on the other hand if we
brought king over to that to the end of
that line it would have fit and it would
have been only 1734 demands
okay
now
um similarly as what about
um if you stopped after a and and just
considered from dot to live I didn't
even show that on here it's not because
the demerits are so large the reason I
didn't show it is because there's
something that Tech calls the the
tolerance in which the old version of
tech called the J par which says
anything that has to stretch too much is
not considered at all
and so we say that a line break is
feasible if there's a way to get there
from the beginning of the paragraph
Without violating any of this tolerances
say that again it's feasible if you can
get there without violating any
tolerances now I've drawn blue lines for
all the feasible breaks in this
paragraph so so you notice at the
beginning we had a feasible break after
ah and after King but whose would make
it too tight lived would have made it
too loose
um
and there's a sort of a v-shaped effect
that is further on you get into the
paragraph the more breaks become
feasible
and if your tolerance was very sloppy
this was done with tight tolerance where
we we had much more rigid space and
controls than Publishers generally do
use so if this if they if we gave
ourselves a lot of Tolerance and we
would have we would probably had all all
uh blue Lines by after we got to down
four or five lines into the paragraph
in Tech 82 if you make a tolerance uh 10
000 or more
Everything is Everything is feasible
and tries everything it wouldn't it
wouldn't mind uh going in space Olden
all the way to the end okay
um so that's there's a notion of in
infinitely feasible but the tolerance uh
is
um is typically 200
um that means uh in units of Badness the
tolerance is now given in units of
Badness it used to be given in another
in other way but tolerance now is giving
units of Badness so
um so if I set the tolerance to 200 that
means that I'm not going to accept any
line whose Badness is more than 200 this
means it would stretch more than a cube
root of two of its uh of its
stretchiness because cube root of two
would when we cubed it would give us two
and then multiply by 100 to get 200.
um so feasible breaks are shown here and
every time I have a blue line I have a
corresponding box down here
and so the question is how what's the
best way to get from the beginning of
the paragraph to the end in the sense of
total
demerits being small as possible this
translates into another well-known
problem in computer science the shortest
path problem what's the best way to get
from here to there uh in the sense that
the total distance should be as short as
possible so if we um so if we knew all
the feasible break points and we knew
all the demerits between feasible break
points and we apply shortest path
algorithm and it gives us the shortest
way to go and uh this one on the top is
the shortest way if you yeah so it's why
we come down through ah instead of going
through King because even though it took
more demerits here we're going to win
pretty soon by take picking up only six
here where that one has to pick up 46.92
in the next line and by putting King in
there you get stuck on the next line you
don't have as good a chance
so
in this way Tech is able to look use the
paragraph as a whole to get the best way
to do the braking
and uh we we use this in the first tech
uh in a a Nas
um well it was it was successfully used
for about two years before we realized
there was a bug in it
um
well before I discussed the about the
bug I should mention
uh that how is the algorithm going to go
on we we don't we don't simply uh go
through one pass through the paragraph
note all the feasible break points
um and demerits set up this graph and
then then start up a shortest path
algorithm the whole thing is all done on
the Fly simultaneously so as we're going
through the paragraph we're keeping
track of as much information as we need
to be able to recognize the feasible
breakpoint when we come to it and at the
same time as that we're also doing the
shortest what the shortest path
algorithm would do on on an acyclic
graph like this
now the broad that we noticed
sometime after it was Illustrated on
this on this chart and the one on the
right hand side is the way it would have
been done by our first algorithm
um
and the slide sort of explains the
problem itself
um if the bug only occurs when the line
with changes and here we have a an
example where the line with changes
and we had been keeping
in our in our diagram for each feasible
break point we had been keeping track of
the best way to get from the beginning
to that break point but we hadn't been
keeping track of the best way to get
from the beginning to that break point
on line 10 as different from the best
way to get to that break point on line
11. but but it might be possible for for
to have the paragraph be feasible
both ending at one place at line 10 and
ending at line 11. okay so in for
example in this case at the end of the
word like
um there's two you know on the left hand
side like fit okay
um we're at the at the end of the um of
the Indian of the indentation there
um well it also fits on on a line above
in fact it'll probably you can probably
squeeze it up some somewhat higher and
find a way to do it feasibly we set
tolerance very high in this particular
example
um so what happened was in our old
algorithm in keeping only the
information for break point and uh
without in without considering line
number we would say that it was the best
way to get from the beginning to light
would be
um uh well that way and and uh then when
we when we come to the lung this uh this
long equation on the next line
and it says now what to do well there's
no way there was no good way to do it
because we had lost track of the fact
that there was a feasible way to get to
this on another line we only kept track
of the best way uh but but no okay I
some of you might see the problem then
as to how our algorithm didn't uh forgot
that there was a feasible way also to
get like at line 11. with each break
point we we stored the best way to get
there and the line number on which it
would be at the best way
we should have done for each combination
of break point and line number store the
best way to get there
so the algorithm that's in the present
version of tech has a bug fixed and does
the thing on the left now I showed this
to some printers and they said the
spacing is so wide on the thing in the
left they would still prefer the one on
the right
um well okay anyway uh it was a bug
so we
uh now those are the only slides I've
got for you on that
question John
on the last slide you mentioned that
you'd keep a feasible way to get a
certain break at a certain line is there
a way also to figure out a feasible
break at arriving at a certain distance
down if you don't know what the line
with spacing is going to be on the way
yeah this this this generalization has
been developed by inyaki and his PhD
thesis and he's uh he's generalized this
algorithm so that it will deal with
shapes uh putting putting text into into
shapes in uh
to me it's amazing that it could ever be
done but but uh the other day he
convinced me that it would work
that's one of the many things that he's
doing in the season now the the uh
um the thing I told you about the merits
isn't quite complete there's also
uh there's also extra demerits thrown in
um for let's see what is it called um
double hyphen demerits is one of them
there's a parameter in Tech A2 that you
say how many demerits do you pay for a
double hyphen two hyphenated lines in a
row and so uh you add to the demerits
that I've already told you how to
calculate this extra penalty
um for double hype and there's another
one for final hyphen demerits this this
applies if you are if you're the at the
end of the paragraph in the previous the
second last line of paragraph Was was
hyphenated and that's a separate panel
uh separate calculation added on to
demerits this is called the merits
rather than penalty because it doesn't
get squared like the uh like penalties
do
now
um
there's also the adjacency demerit and
this is when you have a tight line
followed by a Lewis line or vice versa
um
you you pay a penalty for incompatible
lines in consecutive it's sort of better
if you're going to have a tight line
somewhere and then you you don't want to
have a loose line right afterwards it's
particularly noticeable when when uh
when there's a dramatic switch so
there's there's a lot there's a
calculation based on a bunch of
parameters the user can supply
um
will which then leads to a shortest path
calculation where we try to find the
shortest path now the uh the fact that
we talk about tight lines and loose
lines means that we have to we have to
improve the algorithm still further
along the lines of this uh this bug I
mentioned namely we have to remember for
every break point for every line number
and for every class of Fitness whether
it was tighter or loose on the last one
we have to remember what's the best way
to get there
that triple of things is really what we
have are really the uh the vertices in
our shortest path algorithm
now that um
uh the
idea then was going to be to keep a data
structure that represents
um
that represents enough information for
us to to do all that
and
um
we do it in terms of of the of so-called
passive nodes and active nodes as we're
going through
now as we go as we begin at the
beginning of the paragraph maybe I ought
to put that slide up on the
on the screen again
first I'll wave my hands and then I'll
tell you a little more detail so how do
we actually generate this all on the Fly
we start out and and and there's one
active node uh one active breakpoint and
it's for the beginning of the paragraph
and the the list of active break points
contains only that thing then when we
whenever we get to a valid break we
start searching for the paragraph and
every time we get to a space between
words here that'll be a valid break
point and um the subroutine called try
break is called
and try break looks to see looks at
every active breakpoint
and and every active break point at
first there's only this one
it's it tries to see well what about uh
the best way to get from the beginning
of the paragraph to the current
breakpoint uh via the active breakpoint
now the only way we're ever we're ever
going to get to so suppose our current
breakpoint is called P then we want to
get from beginning
to act to a to P where a is some active
break point
we've already recorded the best way to
get to a so we can figure out the
demerits from a to p and then we know
the cost from beginning to a to P the
best possible weight from beginning to a
to P has to be the best possible way to
a followed by a to p
um
a also includes whether it was tight or
loose this is this is a slight subtlety
and also includes a what line number
there is but I'll I'll uh for Simplicity
just talk about break points so we look
at that number uh and and for all a uh
fixing p and for all a that are
currently active we take the one that
turns out to be best
and if none of those is feasible then we
throw P away and nothing ever happens
but if at least one of them is feasible
the best one gets gets considered an
active break point and it become and and
then it will start testing it against
other things
now
um if
if we find out that there's some active
break point that's uh so far away from P
that from a to P causes these us to
exceed the shrink ability so that we
could never fit the line from a to P in
um to get the current line then a
becomes inactive we take it off the
active list
um
I have to mention I hope that works I
believe that yeah that must be it must
be okay yeah
um so
uh because a has a certain line number
associated with it and it would still
remain active at other line numbers
um
now the uh
um in this case then what's going to
happen we start out with this one active
and after we get to a that one and a
will be active after King we'll test
King against this one and this one
actually
and I will find that
um uh the best one is from the first to
King then when we get to whose we're
going to find out that this one should
be retired so this one becomes inactive
becomes passive
and uh finally when was occurs we'll
find it was should become active and uh
so occurs okay then the next word after
so beautiful a is not going to be no
longer active nor King and So eventually
we'll only keep a few active nodes at a
time so the searches the search uh is is
the number of uh the the time to do this
algorithm is proportional to the number
of break points times the number of
active nodes
and the number of active nodes tends to
be at worst the number of words you can
have in a line
so it so um uh the algorithm runs quite
rapidly
and um
even even when we're setting uh unusual
paragraph shapes we can we can get the
thing that's globally Optimum for the
paragraph as a whole
um with a with a method that uh is only
slightly shorter uh slightly slower than
what you would do if you were just
setting a line at a time on the fly as
another system
uh let's see I wanted to make uh another
quick point but what was it it flashed
through my mind oh it's just I just
wanted to say it's amazing when you play
with this and and you see you correct
the typo in the last line of a paragraph
and then all of a sudden something else
shifts up in the first line
uh after this algorithm goes on
it also does amazing things uh when it
goes wrong as we discovered
for example the mysterious problem was
happening on the current membership list
with the American Mass Society until we
found out that it was that we would that
uh it was because of the final hyphen
penalty the height of the the line
before the last line was hyphenated and
this and wasn't choosing this
alternative as the best one although it
looked obviously better to us than uh
because we didn't realize it was the
line before the end of the of the
paragraph the in the current membership
list they ended the members entries with
uh
um with like a for Association and I for
the the um uh Siam and and as for the
society and uh so the person name given
here and then at the end it says uh
some stars in Sai here would be the
hyphen but but um it would Tech wouldn't
like this this uh solution because we
hadn't realized that the final hyphen
penalty was was uh was was acting there
so it would prefer
um setting something without hyphenating
that word and bringing something over
here and making it look this way and it
uh it surprised us uh so what so there's
so many there's a bunch of parameters in
there and uh and uh if you look at the
code the probably each parameter just
appears once in text program but the uh
the um
uh the art of using these parameters is
uh is something that can be learned but
isn't but what takes a little uh little
experience
I think it's fun to watch it now that
the um
uh I said that we have active nodes and
passive nodes active actually
um we we make up
um
a passive note at the same time as we
make an active node and then when the
node becomes inactive we just we just
recycle the active node part the passive
nodes are are very short for every
feasible break point we have a passive
node that's two words long
um
and uh in fact it could only be one and
a half words long if we if we uh
we're working on a 16-bit instead of a
32-bit uh machine active nodes I forget
how long they are three or four words
long
um each active node points to the
corresponding passive node and also has
these values on it like the the
um the uh total demerits uh the best
total demerits to get to here
and it will contain other things in like
the line number the fitness class
whether it's tight or loose and uh the
and this one points to the break point
P that uh that were that we're actually
trying
the break points that we might find are
at glue nodes or at discretionary nodes
or or
in uh or at penalty nodes and then in
special cases uh math or current node
if uh if you write a math formula and it
says say X
um and somebody has used a math surround
option in Tech which says that he wants
every math form to be surrounded by a
certain amount of space
well then you could break at this at
this uh at this
surround here namely
um if a if a math formula is immediately
followed by a space it's valid to break
there
um and and so that X would be flush
right
um similarly with Kearns if the current
is followed immediately by a space it's
it's allowed to break there so so those
are the kind of legal breakpoints we
have and that's what P represents
something in mem that's either a glue
node or a penalty node or a
discretionary node or
um math or current in these special
cases
the the difference between the the
difference between um text new algorithm
uh the tech 82's algorithm and the one
in the present Tech is primarily that
the present Tech these were these were
both combined in in one big ten word
node
I was taking a lot of memory and what we
had what we did was when it became
inactive we just moved it to a passive
list
um and I just noticed when I was
recoding it that uh we we weren't using
many of those words anymore so now I
just make it up us with the part that's
that I'm going to need at the end
putting immediately on a passive list
the the passive list points to P it
points to the the best previous node
from p in other words the best way to
get to a was from some other passive
node and it points to the previous
passive node so that we can at the end
recycle all the passive nodes uh to the
to the available storage so there's
three pointers in every passive node uh
one and a half words worth active nodes
who contain the total demerits and they
also contain things like the line number
and and I mentioned now that in the in
the existing version of tech
we uh
we we also kept track of the total
length
of of everything from the beginning of
the paragraph to here
the the if you imagine the paragraph all
stretched out in one straight line to
the given point how far uh how much was
there and then and we would use that to
calculate the Badness of a line because
if we knew the beginning 2A and the
beginning to be then for a line from A
to B we subtract those two numbers
well those two numbers were kept in
floating Point notation
and they included and and there was also
a similar thing for stretchability and
shrinkability that we that we would keep
track of in floating point of notation
so that we could determine between A and
B how much stretchability there was
between the line as well as how much
space there was between those two
now
um
that it we want to get rid of floating
Point arithmetic in Tech 82 and it also
led to other problems in the present
version of tech if you ever get this
error message that said too much stretch
for proper line breaking this is because
when you
when you uh took the glue up to
B and subtracted the glue up to a you
got you got Infinity minus infinity
which uh which cancel out to zero it
didn't give you very much information as
to because you because the floating
Point arithmetic all the uh what you
needed was was was was wiped out the
significant figures had had uh the
number of fills in the paragraph but not
uh the details that you needed for the
for line breaking so that was a that
wasn't working properly and the only way
to fix it would be to uh and continue
that same algorithm would have been to
add make these active nodes very large
keeping track of how much glue there was
of type fill of type fillet oil and so
on
um and each of these another 32 bits for
each for each active node but still I
wouldn't be good enough because if you
had a large enough paragraph you'd
overflow I said the other day well who's
going to be caring about Dimensions that
get larger than 17 or eight or whatever
whoever some somewhat feet is concerned
and it's true that B minus a would never
be uh 17 feet but from the beginning of
the paragraph to a given point might
very well get get quite large in fact
we've had
cases where we've seen paragraphs that
run over three pages and uh and you know
the
um we're trying to find the optimum way
to break those pages uh by the way if
you do that it fill memory in another
way probably when you can
and you saw the Triangular effect of
these feasible lines so after you get
into about 30 lines you could just
arbitrarily say Okay break it here this
is going to be a good good place to
break and and uh get get rid of this
paragraph but uh
um certainly we I didn't want to worry
about overflow calculate total length up
to here that would be even on a
reasonable paragraphs uh this would this
would give arithmetic problems so
instead of that
um I've I've got I I keep track only of
relative distances
and the distance is from the first
active node to here is that I keep
so I keep track with the first active
node to here uh for for every node and
then in my active list I have two kinds
of nodes I have actively an active node
another active node and then I have a
call a Delta node
and then another active node let's say
a1a2a3
and so on so Delta nodes can also be in
the active list now and these are nodes
that tell me the different this is the
difference between from from breaking at
A2 to Breaking at A3 so when I pass by a
Delta node it tells me to to you know it
gives me the right information for for
relative distances
relative to A3 well before I had
relative distances relative to A2
so this is a this is a an extra feature
with was added to the data structure in
order to avoid the problem of multiple
Precision arithmetic uh and also making
all these active nodes larger but the
expense of that was of several more
modules of code and several more days of
debugging time and and uh you know uh
but the but it should run fast
however so the so Delta nodes are in
there for this calculation of uh that I
need to figure out the Badness
as you go then
um let's see if we can put ourselves in
in Tech's shoes uh it's trying to to
determine whether p is a feasible
breakpoint it starts at the beginning of
the active list and it has in some table
already are the the length of the line
from a to P from the first node in the
active list to p
then um okay so it can then compute the
Badness uh and see if it's feasible and
uh and then move to A2 if it passes a
Delta node
um adjust its tables of the distances
and go on now the there's uh still more
details to uh
uh to take care of when you when you do
this because you you have uh
uh to figure to to remember that when
when uh you you break at the end of a
line the glue after that break
disappears
and so you really are considering when
you want to figure out the distance from
a break at a to a break at B
what you really have is
um is the is is B uh well I think I call
it bait Alpha of B not C
b b
minus Alpha of a
is the distance from now this means the
distance from the beginning of the
paragraph to before b b beta for before
and Alpha for after to the to a place
after a so if you have a if you have a
uh your paragraph laid out here and
here's B some blue say and here's a then
the length of the line is going to be
from the point after a up to the point
before B
it's not just the distance to B minus
the distance to a it's the distance to
before B minus the distance to after a
and so there's that little difference in
there
okay so um the Delta node that we put in
here is really Alpha A2 minus Alpha A3
because we because if because we're
assuming that our that we know when
we're at this point we have beta of P
minus Alpha of A2 and then when we pass
the note we want to get beta of P minus
Alpha of A3 so the correction Delta is
equal to Alpha A2 minus Alpha A3 that's
the that's the the way you derive these
formulas
so this is the uh the length of the line
that we that we can then compare to the
true uh to the desired length of the of
of whatever line we're we're worried
about
um if the break is at a discretionary
node
for example a simple case where it's a
hyphen or or not a hyphen then we have
to take into account a break point here
we have to say that the Break
um before the hyphen
covers a certain amount of text and the
break after The Hyphen is a certain
amount of text and the meaning of this
notation beta and Alpha has to be
properly defined for discretionaries and
I went around about three iterations
before I finally had that one right
now the the actual width of the line
isn't exactly this though because
another constant has to be thrown in
because Tech 82 has introduced left Skip
and right skip which are added to every
line of a paragraph
um this makes uh things like ragged
right setting and centering very much uh
simpler but it also meant that in my
calculation I have to add this
background information gamma which is
the sum of the left Skip and right Skip
and that gives me the true true size so
with all these qualifications you see
the ideas we start out with some fairly
simple simple ideas and add one or more
complication after another until you
finally get something that can only be
described in web I think with with any
hope of possible success because uh web
allows you to describe one idea at a
time and string them together otherwise
uh it's uh everything is really uh is
really too involved putting it together
now um
okay what more should I say about
this except that we want that it is part
of the inner loop so we also wanted it
to be fast
and um
um I calculated that that uh the the
hyphenation algorithm would not have to
be applied very often this is quite
quite important to uh
uh to uh to the efficiency
um so how do we handle this problem of
hyphenation well here's what here's the
way it goes the the algorithm goes in
two passes on the first pass no
hibernation take place
and instead
um we just keep on trying the algorithm
seeing what we can do try to get the
best uh the best result and unless the
active list becomes empty now in the
diagram that we have there the uh every
time I get to one of the feasible breaks
there was always some way some Escape
out from below it that's not always true
you could certainly get to a place where
where it'd be feasible to get up to
there but nothing feasible after that
point and then if you're in a
conventional type setting system you'd
be stuck you'd have to you'd have to
have a really bad line in in here you
can imagine backing up and going down
another route but we we simultaneously
are are are covering all all bases as we
explore the we keep track of all the
active nodes all the leads at once but
sometimes all of your leads disappear
you got nothing active anymore you're
stuck
um okay then you go to the second pass
the second pass tries hyphenating to get
out of it
and uh every word is hyphenated
every word that that it that that meets
certain conditions is hyphenated
the first condition is that it's got to
be at least five letters there's no
point in trying to hyphenate a
four-letter word because Tech is not
going to hyphenate
um uh ever uh after the first letter or
or less than or less than three letters
after
uh so so Tech Will Never hyphenate a
hyphen something or other
and it will never hyphenate something Ed
it'll always put three letters after The
Hyphen and one and two before so that
means that you've got to have at least
five letters so so why bother trying to
hyphenate a four letter word
um if if the word starts with an
uppercase letter you don't try to
hyphenate it unless the parameter
uppercase hyphenation is is uh set on
right now we're putting it on by default
though because the algorithm seems to
work a lot uh much better we thought it
would on uppercase words
um
if there's something if it's if you're
in the middle of a math formula you
don't try to hyphenate there are some
conditions have to be satisfied but but
otherwise every every word passes this
condition this test and we and we have
to have to submit it to the hyphenation
algorithm well the nice thing was that
in the in the entire book art of
computer programming volume two 700
Pages worth of stuff we could test this
on thousands of paragraphs and we found
out that the average number of
hyphenations we had to try was 1.2 per
paragraph
that was because only one time in 12 did
we have to go into the second pass so
most of the time we could go through on
the first pass find a feasible way to do
the paragraph Without hyphenation Even
though our tolerance was extremely high
so that uh we we had the tolerance so
that uh
um no really bad spaces would would be
allowed at all
and the hyphenation then is is uh seems
to be kept down to us to uh not not
really considered in inner loop
um but if we do have to hyphenate a word
and then the next lecture will be about
hyphenation if we if we do have to
hyphenate a word then
um the hyphenation algorithm just
returns uh the word with discretionary
the same thing uh the list is replaced
by uh another list that's that puts in
discretionaries instead uh in in place
of the word
um so so then Tech proceeds to go
through the the new list with its
discretionaries in it
um it's just as if that was that was
given to it by the user
and uh and applies the same algorithm on
the second path
you might say where do overflow boxes
come from and uh that I can tell you um
that's in the second pass we never allow
the active list to become empty the
activist becomes totally empty we'd be
sunk we'd have no no because at the end
of the paragraph We have to go through
the passive nodes and well I'll tell you
about the end of a paragraph in a minute
but um yeah we lose all contact with uh
with the paragraph if the activist
becomes empty so
um
so there's a time when we determine the
act that we're just about to lose the
active list and at this point
um we uh we we leave something active
even though it's not feasible
and that's where overflow box becomes
created
now the test for when that happened I
might as well find the module exactly
where it is but that was the source of
the of the most difficult bugs in the in
the present version of tech and I and I
changed that at least four times before
getting it right if I had to um
say that there was one one really subtle
part of tech that to name the one that
was that was the hardest for me anyway
uh it would have to be that particular
one and uh let's see if I can find it
um
thank you
let's see
do not lose all active nodes here 744
during the second pass we dare not lose
all active nodes lest we lose touch with
the line breaks already found coach on
here makes sure that such catastrophe
doesn't happen by permitting overflow
boxes The Last Resort uh and uh then it
says readers who seek to improve text
should therefore think Thrice before
daring to make any changes here this
little test if second pass and minimum
demerits equal awful bad and Link of R
is last active and prevar equals active
all four of those were added one at a
time I think and replacing some other
ones then I change the Badness to zero
and
that it
uh
it might take me a while to reconstruct
exactly all the reasoning behind that
one line there but uh but the uh the
computer of course doesn't know that it
was hard to think of so the computer
will just go as fast as ever when it
gets there but but when we're reading it
we we uh we might stop a minute to think
why why did it do that
okay
um that was the part where the Overflow
boxes come in too
um
and uh of course if somebody doesn't
want overflow Boxes by setting the
tolerance to 10 000 you don't get any
you just get uh wonderful ones when when
there's nothing when there's nothing
there
um I found that that for my purpose it
was much better to see overflow because
then I could see where um how much room
there was I I wanted to make a change
anyway I didn't want to leave a a glitch
in my final output
um if I if I don't care about glitches I
said tolerance very high but if I do
care then I want to see this over full
box because it I can look right at it
and see how much it will fit otherwise
if I if it's stretched that one and put
the carry over word in the next line
um takes it you know I have to try to
estimate the sum of all those spaces on
the previous line and how much they
would shrink down and how much room I
have it there this is a visual way to
really see what what kind of Correction
to make
um
now I mentioned uh we got to figure out
what to do at the end we come to the end
of the paragraph and then they they
think is uh to to
actually make the boxes
so
at this point we've got a whole mass of
a whole mess of passive nodes
like for every blue Mark in that line
we've got one of these little passive
mode boxes
and these are all strung together by
Links each one pointing to the previous
one just so that at the end I have a
pointer passive to the last one and uh
at the end I'll just recycle all these
nodes by going through these links and
they all get sent to available storage
but they also contain pointer to the uh
the break point uh where they are
discretionary or something like that
um or a glue or something and they also
contain a pointer to the best previous
place to go so this one will say the
best one for that was here best one for
that was here so let's go over to uh
this slide for example
um at the end of the paragraph
um I uh the best previous thing from
thing must have been her
so I would have a backlink from this one
back to her
and from her it would tell me back to
Ball
and so the pointer you see uh and the
way I've calculated those was as I was
making the thing from the from the
beginning I would keep track for each of
these I would write down the minimum
totally merits from beginning to here
and then the way I got to it what was
the last step in that chain so by going
back from these backlinks that's what
tells us how to do the paragraph
and so I so at the end of the paragraph
I've I've got only one active note and
it's this one then I make it passive
when I look at the corresponding passing
or the passing node points me back to
her that points me back to ball and so
on I'll reconstruct all of the setting
all of the lines as they're as they're
given there so I have to reverse those
links so I can do them in the forward
order so they go through and I I start
at my best my best passive node I go
through and I follow its link you know
maybe 10 lines so it goes down to the
best ninth line eighth line all the way
back to the beginning I reverse those
links so that I now have uh the
appearance of Clairvoyance the beginning
tells me the best way to was to go to
this one and these links are now going
this way and uh telling me the right
thing to do so the remaining thing to do
is take my my my horizontal list and
break it up at these break points these
these things will indicate the 10 break
points as to where I ought to break the
list
um subtle bug that occurred in here uh a
couple years after the first tech was
was uh apparently working well was that
um uh every once in a while we got a a
weird case where where um there would be
a break point uh with some glue and then
there would be some penalty after here
say and then maybe some more glue and
this would be wiped out another penalty
over here so that what usually when we
when we break that glue then we we also
cancel off all penalties uh that
immediately follow it
um but what actually happened one day
was that this penalty turned out to be
one of my best break one of my best
breaks even though this glue was also
one of my best brakes and when I when I
was going through uh boxing the whole
thing I broke here oh I said okay wipe
out all the stuff after all the notes
after it here and then I come to my next
one and it was supposed to go here and I
was out in my available space list and
and starting to point to nothing and you
can imagine all hell with all uh heck
would break loose at this point so now
this um
uh uh so so this is one subtlety that
has to be what these break points might
actually point to nodes that are that
are wiped out but usually they don't and
usually that means that if it's glue you
wipe out the glue here and any penalties
that follow it and then you get to a box
or a character that begins the next line
this becomes your next line so here we
get a box that you send to the hpac
routine hpac routine uh does like we did
before when we made an hbox computes the
height and depth and so on
um it will give the error message about
an over full box and so this we build
now a vertical list
um a vertical is containing the first
line of text then then the Baseline skip
calculations made between all of these
and for each line of text we we build up
another vertical list
now the hpac routine as we send it uh a
sub list of this original paragraph to
be boxed H pack routine not only
calculates this the height and depth and
width of these boxes in blue setting and
things of the box but it also uh looks
for
send enough looks for insert nodes and
readjust nodes that are in that box
um and and those those nodes get
appended right after the Box
so it removes them from inside the box
and they come outside the box that's how
the readjust and things like that get
get worked out
um we also look for penalties uh for
example between the first line and the
second line a widow line penalty is
inserted here
so that uh so that there won't be a
break between these two lines unless you
pay the penalty for widows
there's a penalty for a break after a
line that ends with a hyphen so we also
keep track of that as to whether or not
there's a hyphenated because we don't
like to break a page these breaks are
for page breaks
and so don't like to break a page after
a hyphen if we
if we if we don't have to well yeah
Dan
what about whittling lines at the top of
the next page uh what widowing lines at
the top of the next page yeah so the
second last the Widow penalty is also
inserted here
the um the front there's a final little
there's a there's a final Widow penalty
uh there's a display Widow penalty or
another uh this penalty changes
depending on whether it's a displayed
equation following or not uh Publishers
tend to some Publishers tend to think
it's much better well I think they all
think that it's infinitely better to uh
uh to start a line with a page with a
widow and before displaying to start
with the display itself and so that is a
separate thing in present version of
tech that's a zero but now it's a
special parameter where there's no
reason why we couldn't make so we have a
final we have a pre pre-display penalty
or something like that display Widow
penalty it's called which gets added
before a display but otherwise this one
uh gets there at the beginning and at
the end
there's also Interline penalty which
gets added to all of these guys
and that we recommend for footnotes uh
if you don't want if you want to make up
people pay a penalty for footnotes uh
you pay the Inner Line penalty plus the
Widow penalty for here in a footnote and
and uh just the Inner Line penalty in
here anyway those are those those
penalties are passed in vertical mode
this is now a bunch of boxes in vertical
mode
and the page builder has to decide how
to break that into Pages the page
builder does it one page at a time on
the Fly and uh uses a calculation much
simpler than the uh than the paragraph
Builder because it only has to look at
the Badness not demerits it only takes
the Badness to uh for the current page
and finds the place where the Badness is
and plus penalties is as small as
possible
um so uh the way this this program is
organized then the first section about
breaking paragraphs into lines is
section 37
module 704 and that is basically the
tri-break subroutine and uh all the all
the all the details about how you
calculate these Delta nodes and keep
track of the uh the main maintaining the
active list then section 38 breaking
progress into lines continued that's the
part that talks about running through
the list telling whether or not it's
it's a legal it's legal to break here
calling try break at those places and
SEC and then uh uh doing the final
packaging
um
afterwards the final packaging is done
by a separate procedure because again
this would have otherwise been a
procedure that that some pascals
wouldn't have been able to handle
the hype and now I mentioned that
hyphenation is actually as much code as
the as per as breaking paragraphs and
that's the subject of the next lecture
which we will which will start at in a
half an hour
because you know are rivers considered
all here or they just don't occur
anymore yeah rivers are not looked at as
you can see in this algorithm I don't
have a but the experience has been that
that with good tolerances uh Rivers just
simply are very rare
um but Rivers definitely show up when
you have wide spacing and when you use
the looseness side I didn't mention
looseness
um if if somebody says looseness equals
one then the algorithm will will figure
out the best way to get to the end of a
paragraph
and find out how many lines that took
maybe it was eight lines and then it
will find the best nine not line nine
line way
so we would run through the um the list
at the end this at the end all the
active nodes are the only active node is
the end of paragraph node and those are
all all stopped or those are all marked
with how many lines it took to get here
and so we can say the best way to get
here in nine lines the best way to get
here in 10 lines and uh when you when
you make the paragraph a little loose
then you'll find the best 10 line way to
do it and usually that looks fine but
then somebody says listen it's free
something like that I don't have a slide
here but we can take this paragraph and
set it with looseness 0 1 2 and 3. and
uh minus one actually you can actually
get into one one fewer line and uh
by the time you see looseness two rivers
start to appear
and and this is uh this is typical of
what of what happens if the uh uh but uh
but Rivers also
uh so we're going to generally go away
except uh there's another case where
where I've noticed them um uh we had a
we we typed set a paragraph where out of
an old newspaper which was listing the
people who had attended a wedding it was
Mr and Mrs Smith comma Mr and Mrs Jones
comma and so on and uh you you got a lot
of misters lining up at the left-hand
margin the tech doesn't keep track of
that that has to be manually broken the
uh there's also a theory theoretical
proof that to eliminate Rivers would be
NP complete I mean it's a it would be a
very difficult problem uh to to do it in
the general case and uh since we found
that it it uh was it was not a serious
problem uh anymore we uh there's no
attempt to do anything about rivers here
another guy was he was actually if
somebody's
really believes in this non-foggy
writing and starts to use only three and
four letter words then again you see
Rivers because at the end you have all
three letter words they're going to line
up but there's going to be a white space
near the near the margin on both sides
of the paragraph we've got to use a few
big words once in a while just to just
to kill the rivers
oh yeah one more question
example on the screen there You've Got
Roots through that involve hyphenation
despite the fact that the best fruit
doesn't use anything
um that's true
there was a penalty associated with this
hyphen
that's why 3440 was rather large because
the penalty was added in there
and uh that probably made this branch on
um
uh you know if if uh if this one had
gotten in trouble then then the
hyphenation would have been taken
but this Branch didn't look too good
after we added up all all the other
things but it did try The Hyphen because
in this particular paragraph I oh I see
because you're talking about my second
pass thing no in this case I was uh I I
manually put in all the hyphens uh
because we're making a lot of a lot of
tests on this on this particular
paragraph on very narrow sizes and we
wanted to make sure that that we would
uh that we would get the the truly
Optimum uh setting in this one so we we
imagined that we were going second pass
on this otherwise we wouldn't even
looked at that one
um
yeah but on hyphenation
um I didn't say how I didn't allow all
possible hyphens uh
um I after fa I didn't consider
hyphenating
because I uh I had intended to become
rather conservative about the where
hyphens should be allowed uh
in my own opinion I I believe you should
be able to pronounce the the fragment of
the sentence before looking and if if
you stopped after fa it would have you
might have think it meant father and you
would say far and then you come to the
other say oh faith for it you know and
uh and so I try to uh uh I would like to
to try to avoid hyphen animations uh uh
in places that you couldn't pronounce
the the fragment that you see first
without looking on the next page or next
line okay let's meet at 3 30.
together
thank you